Okay, Michael, so here's a, a nice little concrete example to,
to think about this. Let's pretend that we're no longer in
a world of a single agent like we've been thinking about
with reinforcement learning, but we've gone
full-blown generality to two agents, [LAUGH]
okay? And let's call those agents a and b, and they're
going to be in a very simple game where a gets to make
a choice. And then b gets to make a choice. And
then a might be able to make a choice. So this tree
that I've drawn over on the right is going to capture
the dynamics of this specific game that I'm imagining. So, these
little nodes here, these circles represent states. And we can
think about those in states in the same way that we.
Talked about reinforcement learning in the past. The edges between
these nodes represent actions that one could take. So, this should
look familiar, this is just basically a game tree like
anyone who's taken a, an AI course might have seen. Okay?
>> I guess so.
It doesn't look like a very interesting game.
>> No.
>> But I guess it's a, sort of abstract example.
>> Yes. It's a very simple game just so
that we can get a handle on some basic concepts.
So, in particular, if you look at the details
of this game, you start out in state one. Ok?
And A gets to make a choice between two
actions, going left or going right. If A goes right,
goes right, she ends up in state three. If
she goes left, she ends up in state two. Regardless
B gets to make a choice. From state three we
can choose to go right, and really that's all that can
happen. And this, what happens if B goes right from state
three is that, a value of plus two is assigned to
A, okay? All of these numbers at the bottom, a
the leaves here, are going to be values or rewards if you
want to think about 'em that way that are assigned to
player A. And, in fact, for the purposes of this game,
it's going to be the case that B always get's the opposite
of what A get's. So, if A get's plus 2 then B get's
minus 2, if A get's plus 4 then B get's minus 4,
if A get's minus 1, B get's plus 1, does that make sense?
>> Yeah, though could you write it down so that I won't forget?
>> Okay, that's fine. So, by the way, this is a very specific type
of game. here, and it has a name, which I want to get right.
This is a two-player zero-sum finite deterministic game of perfect information.
So as a, as a title or description of, of this
kind of game, does this make sense to you? Do you
think you know what they all mean, what all those words mean?
>> So, two players because it's a and b,
zero-sum. Because you said the leaves are a's rewards and
b's reward is the negation so if you add
the two rewards together you're always going to get zero.
>> That's
almost right.
>> [LAUGH] Ok.
>> It's not exactly right. Actually, so zero sum really just
means that the sum of the rewards is always a constant.
>> And that constant needs to be zero.
>> It doesn't need to be zero.
>> So if it added up to eleven, that would still be zero sum?
>> If it added up to eleven everywhere. Yes.
>> Huh, okay, interesting choice of
terminology. finite, I don't know, everything seems
to be finite here. There's no infinite number of choices or states or depth.
>> Mhm.
>> deterministic, well, again, thinking about it in an MVPish kind
of way, there's no sort of casting transitions in this particular. Picture.
>> Right. So if I'm in, state two and I
go right, I always end up in state four, period.
>> Right.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Game. I guess, a game is because it's more than one player?
>> Sure.
>> Of perfect information. That doesn't quite sound like the same terminology
that we used in the empty MDP setting. But,
I'm wondering if that's like, I know what state
I'm in, when I'm making a decision. So, it's
like a, like an MDP as apposed to a POMDP.
>> Well it, that's exactly right. It's, it's
that you know what state you're in and. Yeah.
That's exactly what it means. It's like being the
MDP versus the Palm DP. That's a great analogy.
>> Cool. And does it matter that it's a tree like this? because when
we were looking at MDPs, we had more complex structures of graphs and things.
>> Well, you can think of this as unrolling the MDP if you
want to.
>> So then those states are sort of
time stamped and history stamped. For, yeah, for
the purposes of this discussion, yes. And that's
a perfectly reasonable way of thinking about it.
>> But, okay.
>> But in general, we're going to be thinking
about game trees, but actually, we're going through
all of this for nothing, because we're going to
discover pretty soon that none of this matters.
>> [LAUGH]
>> but, give me a couple of slides to get there, okay?
>> [LAUGH] Sure.
>> Okay. So this is about the simplest or at least the, the least
complicated game that you can think
about. Two players, zero sum. Finite deterministic
game of perfect information. You know, basically, I can look at this tree,
I know everything I need to know, and I can make decisions about
what action I might want to take in order to maximize my reward. Okay?
>> Good.
>> All right. Now, in NBPs, of course we had this
notion of. policies, right. You remember what a policy was Michael?
>> Mapping from states to actions.
>> So in the game theory world, we have something very similar to, policies.
We call them strategies. So, all a strategy is, is a mapping of, [LAUGH]
all, of all possible states to actions. So for example, here's a strategy,
that A might have. When in state 1, go left. And when in state 4,
also go left.
>> Seems like a terrible strategy. Does it?
>> Well, just, if nothing else, just in state 4.
>> Sure, but it's a strategy, right?
>> Okay, but it's just, it's a strategy for one of the players.
>> Right, exactly, each player has a strategy. And that makes
sense, right? Before when we talked about a policy, and mapped [UNKNOWN]
to action, there was only ever one player, only ever one
agent. And so we didn't have to worry about what other strategies
there were. Here, when we talk about a strategy, it's always with respect
to one of the players of the game. Okay, so, question. I've just
given you one strategy, which is what A does in all the states
A could potentially end up in. How many other strategies are there for A?
>> For A? Okay, that sounds like a quiz.
>> That does sound like a quiz. Let's make it a quiz.